by Royd cancer is a disease that begins
in your thyroid gland
[Music]
your thyroid gland is located over your
larynx or voice box it wraps around your
trachea or windpipe your thyroid
produces two hormones called thyroid
hormone and calcitonin and secretes them
directly into your bloodstream
inside your thyroid gland follicular
cells make thyroid hormone
your body uses thyroid hormone to
increase your energy and raise your body
temperature when necessary for example
these effects help offset the heat your
body loses when exposed to cold weather
para follicular cells in your thyroid
make calcitonin
calcitonin is thought to stimulate the
formation of new bone
if you have thyroid cancer it may be one
of four types depending on the type of
thyroid cell in which the cancer started
and the appearance of the cancer cells
papillary carcinoma is the most common
thyroid cancer and begins in follicular
cells follicular carcinoma accounts for
one in ten cases and also begins in
follicular cells medullary carcinoma is
less common and starts in Para
follicular cells anaplastic thyroid
carcinoma is a rare more dangerous form
of thyroid cancer
fie roid cancer like all cancers is an
unrestrained growth of cells due to
damaged genetic material in the cell's
nucleus a tumor forms as the cells begin
to accumulate
over time a lump forms in your thyroid
as the tumor enlarges you may feel a
lump in your neck over the thyroid gland
you may have neck or throat pain
hoarseness and trouble swallowing as the
tumor grows around your trachea to treat
thyroid cancer your doctor may recommend
surgery followed by thyroid hormone
therapy radiation therapy or
chemotherapy
surgery is the most common treatment for
all types of thyroid cancer if you have
surgery your doctor will usually remove
your entire thyroid gland
your doctor may remove nearby lymph
nodes as well
after surgery your doctor may recommend
thyroid hormone therapy without your
thyroid your body will have low levels
of thyroid hormone this condition
stimulates the pituitary gland in your
brain to release thyroid stimulating
hormone
increased levels of thyroid stimulating
hormone cause any remaining thyroid
cancer cells to grow faster
if you take thyroid hormone it will
reduce the amount of thyroid stimulating
hormone circulating in your body which
will prevent the cancer cells from
growing
if you have anaplastic thyroid cancer
and have already had surgery your doctor
may recommend radiation therapy such as
external beam radiation therapy
radiation damages and kills any
remaining thyroid cancer cells
after surgery your doctor may give you a
pill containing another type of
radiation therapy called radioactive
iodine
any remaining thyroid cancer cells
absorb the radioactive iodine which
kills them
your doctor may recommend chemotherapy
for anaplastic thyroid cancer that does
not respond to surgery or radiation and
has spread
chemotherapy uses drugs to stop the
progression of cancer by either killing
the cancer cells or preventing further
growth